No, don't, I'm not fancy,
I'm disgusting.
I went to the bathroom,
and then--
and then I was
going to the bathroom,
and then a condom
fell out of me.
Did you pee it
or poop it?
I peed it.
Why'd you immediately
go there?
I didn't poop
it, dude.
Hey, it's 2014.
Anal's on the menu.
I can't even believe that,
like, I didn't notice it.
I was, like, very present,
you know?
I don't know how
he didn't notice it.
It happens
to everybody.
Has it happened to you?
No.
(sighs)
Everything I've done
has happened to you.
Not yet is what
I meant to say.
So what? You're a nasty
bitch, who cares?
All right.
(sighs)
Let's go get high,
and then we can enjoy this
clams Filipino even more.
Okay.
That's a good idea.
Hi, would you mind
making sure
they don't
take those clams?
Thank you.
You know, I know you're
in your head, but...
this birthday
is a maje improvement
from last year's.
(inhales)
Yeah, well,
I shouldn't have tried
to throw myself
a surprise party.
You should have tried.
It was a mistake.
Hi.
Want a hit?
Thanks for the food.
It's amazingly
delicious.
I don't prepare
the food.
I just, uh,
clear the plates.
Yeah, but... you know.
You know what I've been
thinking about?
Every animal,
from every movie
we've loved as a kid,
probably dead.
Think about it.
Air Bud: dead.
All 101 Dalmatians
are probably dead.
(shudders)
I guess Babe
from "Babe" is dead.
Ooh, we could have
eaten Babe tonight.
Well, maybe not.
Pigs live longer
than dogs.
I think they might live
longer than humans?
I think
that's turtles.
Tramp, from
"Lady and the Tramp."
(laughing)
Tramp's a cartoon.
I know that.
She was for real.
I know that it was a cartoon.
Uh, I gotta go,
but thanks.
No worries.
Hey, and I know you
didn't make the food,
but you will one day.
Uh... thanks.
You know, that Tramp was
my first sexual crush.
He was hot. He was like
a spunky bad boy.
You know who
was mine? Stimpy.
Stimpy from
"Ren and Stimpy"?
Yeah, I feel like he has
a similar build to Lincoln.
Huh.